Traductor: Silvina Katz
Revisor: Paula Motter
Es otra mañana sofocante
en Menfis, Egipto.
A medida que la luz del sol ilumina
el Nilo, Peseshet revisa sus provisiones.
Miel,
ajo,
comino,
hojas de acacia,
aceite de cedro.
Está provista con los elementos
esenciales para tratar a sus pacientes.
Peseshet es "swnw", o médica.
Para ser médica
tuvo que prepararse para ser escriba
y estudiar los papiros médicos guardados
en Per Ankh, la Casa de la Vida.
Ahora, tiene allí sus propios discípulos.
Antes de la clase, Peseshet
debe examinar a un paciente.
Uno de los trabajadores en el solar
del templo se ha lastimado el brazo.
Al llegar, Peseshet nota que
lo tiene visiblemente quebrado
y, para peor, el hueso
se ha fracturado en varias partes.
Peseshet venda e inmoviliza la lesión.
Su próximo destino es la Casa de la Vida.
En el camino, una mujer
intercepta a Peseshet en la calle.
El hijo de la mujer
fue picado por un escorpión.
Peseshet ha visto picaduras similares
y sabe exactamente qué hacer.
Debe decir un conjuro
para expulsar el veneno.
Comienza a recitar el hechizo,
invocando a Serqet, patrona de los médicos
y diosa de las criaturas venenosas.
Peseshet recita el hechizo
como si ella misma fuera Serqet.
Esta estrategia de superioridad
garantiza mayor posibilidad de éxito.
Después de pronunciar la última línea,
trata de quitar el veneno
con un cuchillo, para asegurarse.
Peseshet se dispone a marcharse,
pero la mujer tiene otra pregunta.
Quiere saber si está encinta.
Peseshet le explica su infalible
prueba de embarazo.
Debe plantar dos semillas:
una de cebada, otra de farro;
luego, debe orinar en las semillas
todos los días.
Si las plantas crecen, está embarazada.
La planta de cebada predice un varón,
mientras que la de farro predice una niña.
Peseshet también recomienda orarle
a Hathor, diosa de la fertilidad.
Cuando Peseshet finalmente
llega a la Casa de la Vida,
se encuentra
con el médico-sacerdote Isesi.
Lo saluda con cortesía, pero
los sacerdotes le resultan engreídos.
Peseshet no envidia el papel
de Isesi como "neru pehut",
que se traduce como "pastor
del ano de la familia real",
o "guardián del ano real".
En el interior, la Casa de la Vida
se llena con el habitual bullicio
de los escribas
sacerdotes,
médicos
y discípulos.
Los papiros, que contienen todo tipo
de registros, no solo información médica,
están guardados en este sitio.
El hijo de Peseshet, Akhethetep,
trabaja arduamente copiando documentos
como parte del entrenamiento
para ser escriba.
Es un estudiante muy prometedor,
pero se le permitió estudiar
porque Peseshet es escriba,
como lo fue su padre antes que ella.
Sin familiares en la profesión,
es muy difícil para los niños,
e imposible para las niñas,
acceder a esta educación.
Peseshet supervisa a todas las "swnws"
y aprendices de "swnws" en Menfis.
Los hombres tienen su propio supervisor,
pues los médicos varones
no responden a una mujer.
Hoy, Peseshet enseña anatomía.
Evalúa a sus discípulos sobre el "metu",
los vasos del cuerpo
que transportan sangre,
aire,
orina
e incluso malos espíritus.
Peseshet se dispone a partir
cuando una mujer pálida y delgada
la aborda en la puerta
y le suplica que la atienda.
Debajo del brazo, tiene un gran
bulto que le causa dolor.
Peseshet palpa la protuberancia
y le resulta fría al tacto,
dura como una fruta sin madurar.
Ha leído sobre dolencias como
esta, pero nunca había visto una.
Para este tumor no hay tratamiento,
ni remedio, ni hechizo.
Todos los textos dan
el mismo consejo: no hacer nada.
Luego de dar la mala noticia,
Peseshet sale del lugar.
Se demora en la escalinata
de la Casa de la Vida
para admirar la ciudad al atardecer.
A pesar de tan arduo trabajo,
siempre habrá pacientes
a los que no puede ayudar,
como la mujer con el tumor.
Se quedan con ella, pero Peseshet
no tiene tiempo que perder.
En pocas semanas, comenzará
la anual crecida del Nilo,
dando vida al suelo para
la cosecha del próximo año
y a un nuevo flujo de pacientes.